okay okay great well think some things
to everyone for coming and I'm sorry
that we're starting late and it's
entirely my fault the one the one
dispensable member of this panel that
couldn't make it sharp at 10 but I I'm
looking forward to this discussion I was
uh I was based in Kiev in the early 90s
from about actually Martha and I were
overlapped when I guess you were doing
your PhD research and doing some some
journalism to for the Guardian and 44
radio and I haven't been back for a few
years I wish we were here it's slightly
more hopeful times for for Ukraine but
hopefully we can also find a lot of
positive things as well and I think sort
of obviously media I mean I have a very
personal interest in in a free media but
it's so central to you know how a free
society is supposed to work so let me
just get going to be our late this is
the media market and democracy Ukraine
in the global context and let me start
with with Marta who's the one person
here who I've known for a long time and
we didn't meet in Kiev I guess it was
just the turn of the craft shook to
Kojima era and you know the time when
Ukraine started to really become a
proper nation-state and really
consolidate its its it's a democracy
Martha since then has got her PhD from
Oxford and has moved into academia in in
Canada and teachers I guess both history
and NBN political science at the
University of Western Ontario also Todd
back in Kiev at the key of Manila
Academy and let's just turn over to her
thank you
you can hear me better is this
microphone working beautiful because I
have a soft voice and I can never be
heard without the microphone thank you
very much all for coming on this
beautiful friday morning at Columbia
University I'd like to start by thanking
professor Mark and the day chick who is
the brains behind this whole operation
he came up with this idea to hold the
conference on mass media in Ukraine
which is the topic that is still under
studied in the larger context of
Ukrainian studies and post-communist
studies and I'd also like to thank
especially Matthew Kaminski for joining
us today he's explained that he worked
as a journalist in Ukraine in the early
1990s and after that he did such a good
job he got promoted to the Paris office
of the Wall Street Journal and for the
last few years he's been based here in
New York and as you see he's extremely
busy so we're just delighted that he was
able to join us here and look forward to
his comments on what we're talking about
and I'm just going to point her so that
I can move through this the title of my
talk is you can see is Ukraine's oops
Ukraine's media in the context of global
cultural convergence when I mention this
to my friend in Toronto she said oh my
god that sounds really serious and then
I got a message from a friend in cave on
facebook when I posted the program and
he said wow someone's going to be
talking about Ukraine in a global
context because so often people who
study Ukraine study it in and of itself
or perhaps in reference to some
normative standards of democracy or
media freedom that don't really exist
anywhere so what I'd like to talk about
is how Ukraine's media fits into larger
global trends Ukraine became independent
around the time that the modern version
of globalization really took off so
Ukraine has been redefining its identity
in the context of larger global changes
and mass media has been at the center of
this after 20 years of Ukraine's
independence most Ukrainians identify
themselves as Ukrainians
but if we look at what Ukrainians are
watching on television it is strikingly
similar to what Americans and Canadians
and Germans are watching on television
sports entertainment sitcoms reality
shows this is dramatically different
from the situation in 1990-91 when
Ukrainians had access to three
state-owned state control channels and
state control content media is often at
the center of power struggles and often
the discussions about media are about
censorship and politics which is what
one of the themes of this conference is
another way of looking at the issues is
that media is at the center for the
struggle over identity that the way
Ukrainians see each other see themselves
and their relationship with the world is
both shaped by and reflected in media
representations once Ukraine became
independent it became part of McLuhan's
Global Village and this struggle over
redefining who Ukrainians are has been
happening in this larger context of
globalization when the USSR collapsed
the category of a Soviet identity
disappeared so Ukrainians had to
redefine who they are and how they
interact with the world the French there
is birju has suggested that when this
process occurs there's a number of
things that are happening institutional
structures change values change and
there's a social change that occurs that
shapes this identity struggle and the
big change is in how values are being
shaped Ukraine has been undergoing all
of these changes and in amidst the
process of nation and state building the
state has not imposed a single vision of
Ukrainian asst from above no government
has actually defined this is what it
means to be Ukrainian
the other thing that's been happening
while all of these larger changes is the
media landscape has been changing
radically and the way that media has
changed is that it has become privately
owned predominantly it has diversified
it has grown and media owners are
largely driven by not democratic
considerations but like elsewhere by
profits and by corporate interests what
I'd like to suggest is by looking at
media or on the public sphere with the
diversification there's a lot of
different kinds of media in Ukraine so
the public sphere that habermas used to
write about has splintered into what
todd gitlin has called public sphere
accuse so now there's lots of different
kinds of media available and you can
find whatever you're looking for because
there isn't one single public space and
the state is not imposing a special
vision of a single vision of what
Ukraine should be looking like media
systems became globally integrated
around the time that Ukraine went into
became independent what we see happening
globally is ownership structures
converge and we have these large global
media systems that are dominated by a
handful of countries led by the United
States and various others the media
content is shaped and produced primarily
by a handful of countries the values
that are shaped through the media are
coming from these countries scholars
have been writing about this and looking
at the impact of this global convergence
of media where you have a handful of
producers of media content that's being
broadcast globally what impact this is
having on global culture and there's a
divide in the literature on this some
think this is a positive thing that we
will now have global norms and everybody
will have the same value system and this
will lead to prosperity
and global stability because we're all
going to have the same values of
democracy market economy and so on
critical scholars think very differently
and they point to what they call the
dangers of American cultural imperialism
that a certain set of value systems is
now being globally transmitted through
these global media systems so the the
discussion is often what these global
media systems are doing toward to local
national when they say local they mean
national media systems and media
cultures or national cultures in Ukraine
of the reaction to all of this again the
literature here is divided some talk
about media convergence that everybody's
buying into the same way of thinking in
the same value system others point to
examples of rejection of this
Americanization or westernization a
third and this is the one that I find
most convincing and this is a pepper
Morris from Harvard has written about
this an amalgamation where Western
formats are adopted and then adapted to
produce a hybrid so it's taking Western
formats but giving them in our case that
Ukrainian flavor what I see happening in
Ukraine is it's not just this global
national dimension there's a third
factor in Ukraine and I've called that
the Russia factor Ukraine is not only
subjected to these forces of
globalization that are being spread
everywhere Ukraine is also being
subjected to cultural forces coming from
Russia as a result of this oops i went
ahead a little bit of myself there what
we see in media representations in
Ukraine are at least three different
visions of what it means to be Ukrainian
as they said I don't believe there's a
consensus in Ukraine what it means to be
Ukrainian through media representations
I see at least three different ways
Ukrainians are
finding themselves one is the
cosmopolitan vision people who are
embracing the forces of globalization
the Western values another is what i
call the residual soviet identity these
are people who are still culturally
closer to Russia and adopting that way
of seeing the world this is the
continued impact of the Russia factor
through media content that's coming from
Russia and a third one is what I've
called a new old ukrainian identity and
this one's the most controversial so I'm
looking forward to your feedback on this
one this is people who see themselves as
Ukrainians they're drawing for on their
identity with from Ukrainian cultural
history and patterns sometimes with
looking at issues of democracy that are
universal but a Ukrainian flavor to that
what was my next light all of these the
impact of all of this has very serious
implications for democracy political
scientists and media scholars have been
writing about the impact of global media
convergence on politics and we often
when we look at Ukraine we focus on the
problems that are happening in that
country with its democratization process
what I'd like to suggest is we look at
things in a more global sense politics
are changing globally and media and
particularly television is an important
factor in changing the way politicians
interact with society and one of my
favorite authors here is Paolo Mancini
an Italian scholar who writes mainly
about Italy and what's going on in the
media in Italy but i think his
analytical framework is useful globally
what he and others write about is a
deterioration of traditional
institutions like political parties and
civic organizations other people like
Putnam have written about this as well
and what's happening in societies as
societies are being turned into
audiences and he uses the phrase
audience democracy so instead of being
active citizens they're positive viewers
and this is all happening through
television and television is
selling a lifestyle and we see
politicians adopting certain values and
transmitting this into society and these
values are not always Democratic whant
how does this all how is this all
relevant to Ukraine a lot of these
patterns I argue are visible and what's
happening in Ukrainian society and how
this is happening through media and this
is where i'm going to count on that as
the moderator to help me with the time
because i have a lot more material to
get through so how am i doing but
halfway through about half way out okay
beautiful ukraine's but the current
discussions over ukrainians identity are
rooted in the past ukraine was a Soviet
part of the Soviet Union for over 70
years and the legacies from the Soviet
era are still very relevant in the way
Ukrainians are thinking about who they
are and defining themselves so the
values from the past continue to be
relevant in the way the discussions over
identity are happening in the Soviet
period and I'll go through this very
very quickly the Soviet Union attempted
to create a new kind of identity the
Soviet person to large degree was
unsuccessful because the Soviet Union
fell apart so I call this the imperfect
Soviet hegemon it never actually
succeeded in creating a Soviet identity
it was never monolithic or static during
the glasnost years the discussions over
identity widen and when Gorbachev
loosens restrictions / media discourse
we have this national element coming up
in the discourse censorship officially
ends in 1990s during the glossners years
and also the state gives up monopoly on
media ownership during the glass last
year's so Ukraine becomes independent
and the key question is what kind of
Ukraine should be built Ukraine's first
president will need prochik did not
impose a vision of what Ukraine should
be on to society when I interviewed him
in 2011
asked him what vision did you have for
Ukraine's media what were you what kind
of a system were you trying to set up
and he somehow didn't seem to understand
the question he said well what do you
mean and I said well one of the things
you were doing was reorganizing the
media system and he sort of thought
about and he said well we wanted to
build democracy we wanted to build an
independent Ukraine it was sort of vague
what what is what he was imagining how
this should all be the media system
during the first years of independence
continued to be state-owned so although
privatization was allowed we have the
beginning of new media private private
media outlets appearing but this process
is happening very slowly in the first
few years so the first period of
Ukraine's independence we're looking at
a media system that is still largely
state-owned and state control that said
there's a lot of innovation happening oh
the main television in Ukraine in the
early 1990s is still the Russian of
thunk ela channel until nineteen
ninety-four most Ukrainians are still
watching the Russian channel that said
there's a lot of innovation that's
happening on state television I standard
equal across smiling i don't know
Matthew if you recognize the photo this
is a show that aired in 1994 this is
Alexander Kachin go way back then he
introduced the first analytical weekly
news show on Ukrainian television and if
you look at the images I don't know
clear that you can see them this is the
representation of the cosmopolitan
Ukrainian he's got the Eiffel Tower he
for the he has a vision of Ukraine
looking out to the world and being part
of the global community another thing we
see happening in that period is looking
back at Ukraine's historical identity
there's a series of historical films
called naveed or mocha tienda that are
produced at this time and also broadcast
on the state broadcaster looking at the
unknown pages of Ukrainian history that
have been suppressed or silenced during
the Soviet
another thing we're seeing on Ukrainian
state television in the very early years
is the broadcasting of Western
programming they start by showing the
what the Latino telenovelas because
those are less expensive than the
Hollywood sitcoms so they can't afford
the high end stuff initially but this is
sort of just adapting are not adapting
this is just taking the Western model
and and just broadcasting all of these
are popular new legislation is adopted
in this time period the other thing that
happens in the very early phases is we
see the first Western TV company in
Ukraine and this is I see TV which our
main speaker yesterday now works for but
it was set out by two Americans and it
was set up by this company called story
first communications they couldn't
broadcast on the main channels so they
were broadcasting on these small
regional channels what were they
broadcasting they were broadcasting
American sitcoms they became the fourth
most popular channel in Ukraine in the
early 90s with this type of programming
so there was a lot of interest in this
kind of looking out to the world and
Western formats what happens in the mid
1990s the Ukraine's media landscape is
fundamentally transformed in couch most
first presidency he does a number of
things that will set the pattern that we
still have today the regulatory
framework that he sets up the first
thing he does is he takes control over
the broadcast space because up until
nineteen ninety-four Russia is still
broadcasting on the main channel so most
Ukrainians are still watching Russian
television and a presidential decree he
changes on and he takes control over
broadcasting on Ukrainian territory and
the Russian channels are not banned from
being broadcast they're just not
broadcast on the main three channels at
this time there's only three channels
with national broadcast reach so he
takes that's the first thing he does and
then he sets up a legislative framework
all sorts of things all sorts of laws
including protection and freedom of
speech in the Constitution what he does
not do is he does not
a single vision of Ukrainian identity he
does not say this is how Ukrainian
identity should be represented in terms
of political economy he changes the
owner strip structure fundamentally and
what we see here is the privatization
the serious privatization of the media
particularly the TV space happens in
couch most first period the way he does
it is norm transparent and the groups
who have contacts with the presidential
administration are giving preferential
access and they are allowed to privatize
there are three main channels in Ukraine
at the time two of them are transferred
to private hands the way this is done as
I said I think we all know was very non
transparent one plus one and in Ted are
the two new private channels that appear
at this time and these continue to be
the leaders in Ukraine's television
these are the most popular most powerful
because they had the early start however
they had very different visions of what
Ukrainian television should be and one
plus one is set out by three people are
with me on ski louder and that'll be
knowledge this is an American
millionaire a Ukrainian filmmaker who's
lived in the West and a shady
businessman they create this channel
studio 1 plus 1 and their mission is to
create an image of Ukrainians as hip
modern it's Ukrainian speaking they
broadcast Ukrainian programs also a lot
of Western programs they set up the best
news show at the time to sm which
continues to exist but when they just
set it up it was the best news program
in ukraine int it is the other
television chase private station that
set up at this time very different
owners set this up this is set up by the
cave clan krishna grove is a major
player in the cave all early oligarchs
the state property fund and russian
television ort has thirty percent of
that what kind of TV station did they
set up what vision do they have this is
the Soviet residual identity
they're broadcasting a lot of Soviet
programming old movies the news that
they broadcast on that show is vremya
it's the Russian the Soviet that becomes
Russian news in Russian and that
continues until 2001 so there they have
a very different vision of what
television and what Ukrainians want
although then stays in state hands
because coachman doesn't want to
privatize everything and that continues
to be Ukrainian language not very
interesting programming because all the
innovators have moved to the private
channels so here we see those three very
different visions of what it means to be
Ukrainian now 1+1 an ink that both get
large audiences they establish
themselves as popular channels right
from the beginning and they continue to
have a competition for ratings until the
censorship intensifies in couch metoo so
we have a diversification and very
different kinds of programs and
Ukrainians are interested in different
things what happens in the second period
of Kojima's presidency this is what I
call the unusual convergence and the
Dean of journalism at Cave mahalia ven
fetch uncle he's called this period as
the the worst of both worlds were the
value systems from the Soviet period
social justice and hard work that's
pretty much disappeared from public
disgrace the negative things from the
Soviet period corruption
authoritarianism that's very much there
and growing on the other hand the
Western cosmopolitan vision the the
positive sides of Western
cosmopolitanism democracy rule of law is
receding what's increasing are the less
good things the individualism the
consumerism so you've got the value
systems from these two visions and the
worst of all of that is converging and
we see this happening in media
representations in terms of ownership
structures what happens in this period
is inter
is most of the foreign owners are
squeezed out of the Ukrainian market so
control over the representational
struggle becomes almost exclusively in
Ukrainian hands these three channels
become part of one media holding and
this is the larger pattern we see we see
the concentration of media ownership
that is the pattern in Western countries
and globally so Ukraine is now adopting
that